[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro de la grande interview le
confinement imposé par la pandémie
coronavirus pourrait bien engendrer une
hausse des violences conjugales voire
même des féminicides et pour parer à
cette situation le gouvernement en lien
avec des associations a mis en place des
moyens pour les victimes pour aider les
victimes à échapper à leurs bourreaux
on va on va en parler avec notre invité
noël agosta il est président de
l'association des familles victimes des
féminicides noël à gossas bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france - jours à
pau merci alors le confinement que nous
vivons depuis plus d'un mois maintenant
at il eu des conséquences directes sur
les violences conjugales
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas défini ci
d'aujourd'hui en france alors absolument
ce qu'il faut quand même signaler que
c'est le sait le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en a huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences le nombre en quoi accroît
accroît sensiblement et difficilement
tant que c'est clair que ce confinement
la augmente les tensions les coûts les
violences de harcèlement les menaces et
ça se ressent aussi dans les dans les
sphères cancer national et même
peut-être internationale en fait alors
justement en quoi cette période est
encore plus angoissante pour pour ces
femmes victimes de violences qu'est ce
qu'elle vous témoigne bon vous savez les
coûts et les violences existait avant le
confinement et pendant ce confinement
c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce cadre les
captures en tant qu est ce qu on dit
souvent ce sont les 4 8 ans cet enclos
ce huis clos aussi fait que les
possibilités de sortir trentenaire aller
toquer chez là où chez la voisine appelé
une amie pour se ressourcer pour en
parler c'est impossible
donc on peu plus chères elles ne peuvent
plus aller sortir en discuter ce faire
emprunter justice voilà donc c'est un
peu difficile pour elle donc du coup les
femmes fraysse isolé au sein de
film là et c'est une double peine en
fait pour l escaut du coup on peut
craindre avec cette situation
un risque de mort plus important pour
ces femmes et bien sûr bien sûr les là
en dehors des chiffres officiels en
aujourd'hui de défi mini side est très
familiale et de file ministry de
conjugale des chiffres montent montent
en flèche
c'est triste mais on entend le craindre
là qu'on l'a craint un peu avant par
rapport au grenelle qui a eu il ya
quelques temps malheureusement les
choses ne sont pas aujourd'hui au point
pas pour retracer les anti rapprochement
pour certains conjoints violents
donc il ya pas mal de chose qui peut qui
auraient pu être évitées aussi en amont
est là aujourd'hui avec ce confinement
là les taux de féminicide a plus que je
dis pas doublé mais bien monté forcément
on n'a pas encore tous les chiffres
officiels c'est très difficile mais quoi
qu'il en soit les violences ont augmenté
sensiblement
alors on sert des plateformes d'écouté
de signalement
ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement néanmoins en cette période
de confinement est ce que ces
plateformes sont efficaces sachant vous
l'avez rappelé que le bourreau n'est
jamais n'est jamais loin finalement
mais bien sûr le bourreau état est à
zéro m 2 de la victime
imaginez on parle souvent de 39 19 donc
une plateforme d'appels d'écouté et
d'orientation
le gouvernement a mis en place aussi ont
un site internet une adresse pour les
victimes aussi et étalement aussi un sms
dans le sens 14
bon vous savez aujourd'hui nous notre
côté on a créé une plateforme par
rapport au confinement qui s'appelle
sauf urgence femme ou certaines femmes
ont sont exfiltrés émis dans des
appartements que des proprétaires que je
remercie d'ailleurs mettre à notre
disposition pour qu'on puisse les
protéger tout de suite voilà en
attendant les les poursuites judiciaires
et autres qui peuvent prendre du temps
donc aujourd'hui les plateformes c'est
bien de donner des numéros pression des
gens qui s'appelait plein numéros ont
été sortis c'est vrai mais il n'y a
qu'un seul numéro aujourd'hui lorsqu'il
ya un danger c'est le 17 c'est la police
dans ses yeux qui sont en première ligne
pour intervenir en cas de violences en
tas de mise en danger
donc nous on n'est pas contre que ce
numéro là au contraire s'ils sont les
numéros des plateformes utile mais il
faut rappeler aussi que l'urgence vitale
à procès femmes par rapport au
féminicide c'est le 17 c'est très très
important et c'est très très bien a
rappelé alors vous le disiez avec votre
association vous permettait donc à ces
femmes de s'éloigner de leur bourreau en
leur proposant des logements mais très
concrètement comment ça se passe comment
ça se passe
nadhir une femme à partir du moment où
elle est battue où elle est en entendant
en danger de mort qu'est ce qu'elle doit
faire
alors donc en dehors des numéros qui
existent le 17 et autres nous ce qui se
passe on a une adresse email on est très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux
ces femmes nous écrivent en une bosse
sur facebook par exemple et parfois par
mail nous on est comme une icône hymne
au téléphone privé
on échange avec elle qui selon
l'association aussi était qu'elles
peuvent sortir des cl parce que
certaines n'appelle plus la police parce
qu'ils ont plus confiance m
moi ça arrive et celles qui peuvent
elles nous donneront les donnent rendez
vous sur un point précis on passe et
récupérer discrètement et on n'est pas
dans des appartements
voilà donc c'est tout simplement ça nous
ce qu'on fait actuellement depuis un
mois par rapport au confinement danser
c'est du concret c'est sur le terrain on
n'a pas attendu d des numéros simplement
théâtre adresse mail supplémentaire du
gouvernement pour agir parce que
malheureusement au sein de l'association
il ya des victimes de violence mais
aussi des familles des victimes de
féminicide donc on est vraiment au coeur
au coeur de ce problème n'a en fait il
ne peut pas laisser les choses se faire
comme le bracelet électronique comme
d'autres mesures qui doivent être prises
depuis le mois de janvier on attendu
longtemps on est au mois d'avril dans
quatre mois
les bras ce ne sont pas encore au en
place les commissariats ne sont pas pro
doté de deux d'agents formés pour les
causes urgentes par pau violence il ya
plein de choses qui sont pas encore au
point
donc nous on s'est dit on va pas
attendre cela parce qu'on a souvent des
demandes pas tous les jours mais très
souvent des demandes d'urgence donc on à
refaire à la police mais parfois aussi
on si on peut aider directement on le
fait et l'exfiltration de ces femmes en
danger que vous proposez est-ce que vous
la faite en lien justement avec les
forces de police avec la justice
alors il n'ya pas très longtemps et
après une semaine la police a filtré
dans cet incident inverse
bizarrement on nomme parce qu'on a c'est
qu'on a fait un signalement à celui
voilà parce que le but aussi c'est que
la femme à la base puisse rester au sein
du foyer ça c'est d'urgence et là c'est
la meilleure solution en termes de
protection
maintenant si ces femmes ne peuvent plus
rester souvent alors aujourd'hui en tout
cas au capot en lui ces femmes s'isole
arrive à sortir disent qu'ils vont aller
faire des courses ou aller voir des amis
que je fais et c'est la côte où nous on
intervient en fait voilà pour l'instant
c'est sans la police pour la majeure
partie des cas parce que encore une fois
ces femmes là nous ne voulait pas dans
un premier temps que les forces de
l'ordre puissent agir par peur de
représailles
justement est-ce que les forces de
l'ordre selon vous sont suffisamment
sensibilisés à ces situations
aujourd'hui et particulièrement en cette
période de confinement oui j'avoue
qu'actuellement les choses évoluent
aussi
1 j'ai toujours critiquer hills à
l'intérieur sur ses positions
mais il est vrai qu'actuellement les
phases de leur sont aussi sur le quai
vif succès sur ces problématiques
mais c'est pas suffisant encore une fois
ce n'est pas suffisant s'il y a il ya
une progression
ça se voit on le sent on a des retombées
là dessus mais ce n'est pas encore
suffisant et on encourage en tout cas le
gouvernement à poursuivre ses efforts
notamment le lan le ministère de la
justice aussi derrière et le ministère
de l'intérieur à poursuivre les efforts
à former encore plus les policiers en
termes d' écoute en termes d'action
aussi ça c'est très important parce que
c'est ce que les victimes critique
souvent les écoutes ne sont pas ne sont
pas claires les écoutes elles elles ne
sont pas très écoutée en terme de
on les croit pas pour certains ça on a
tellement dit et la l2 puis c'est
vraiment qu'on puisse avoir un consensus
que dès qu'une femme appelle le
commissariat
qu'elles soient écoutés qu'elles soient
crus tout de suite et ensuite qu'on
puisse faire les choses qui vont suivre
avril après quand le agir tout de suite
maintenant ou après mais tout de suite
il faut que les les femmes pu être
rassuré comme pas leur problème est
urgent le problème est vrai et pas
inventé tout le temps alors vous parliez
tout à l'heure d'un homme qui a été
exfiltré par la police parce qu'il était
violent il existe aussi une plateforme
d'écouté justement pour ses maris
violents
pour qu'ils appellent avant de passer à
l'acte qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est efficace mais c'est une
très belle chose c'est une très belle
initiative parce que aussi la prévention
du des féminicides de toutes ces
violences est importante il faut aussi
rééduquer le système réduit qu'est la
citoyenneté et les zones qui sont
violents et qui pensent qu'elles peuvent
agir sous l'effet de l'alcool sous
l'effet de drogues sous l'effet d'une
colère qui peuvent dépasser dans leurs
paroles
ces personnes à apprendre qu'on prenne
conscience de cela et qu elle puisse
appeler une plateforme pour se faire
aider
on ne peut qu'applaudir ça évite
forcément des drames
donc on ne peut que peu encouragé le
gouvernement à aller dans ce sens là
aussi pour éviter les les féminicides
alors la justice est elle aussi bousculé
en cette période de confinement qu'est
ce que vous en attendez vous très
concrètement vous savez il ya une pièce
d'un d'un aurélien je me suis un peu de
discernement en fait la pièce appelée
une maison de poupée maison de poupée et
qui daté de 1789 ans ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui et danse au confinement là
en fait on s'aperçoit que eux on
s'adresse particulièrement à la justice
pourquoi parce que la justice
aujourd'hui en france à des moyens sont
des moyens que qu'elle ne met pas au
coeur du système
j'ai parlé de bracelet anti
rapprochement qui a été votée depuis
deux ans qu'il débute mis en place au
mois de janvier d'après le trénel on est
au mois d'avril
sap a été mis il ya des sanctions vous
savez aujourd'hui pour revenir sur les
féminicides lorsqu'une personne puis une
femme parce que c'est une femme
l'encours entre hal et 15 ans et 20 ans
on parle de perpétuité
aujourd'hui en france et dans l'est dans
les cas les plus les plus vérifiable
ces personnes là ne dépasse pas 12 ans
imaginez donc je donne mais c'est de la
justice pour vérifier tout ça donc
aujourd'hui en france on peut tuer une
personne une femme sortir au bout de
sept ans bout de huit ans donc les
peines ne sont pas assez sévères
donc la justice a aussi du mal à mettre
un point d'honneur à sanctionner
véritablement et correctement donc on
est bon on éduque on sensibilise mais il
faut aussi sanctionner ça permettra de
sauver des vies dans ces importants de
sanctions c'est pourtant deux points des
musiques les musées de précaution par
rapport au bracelet mais il faut aussi
que les sanctions soient réels pour
conclure noël à gossas il nous reste
quelques secondes
c'est aussi la famille qui est concerné
c'est aussi
le voisinage alors quelle attitude
adopter en cas de doute mais en cas de
doute de il faut crier il faut appeler
au secours
votre maison vous savez aujourd'hui la
citoyenneté de vivre ensemble c'est pas
que des mots dans des foyers que ce soit
dans des appartements dans des pavillons
autres lorsqu'on est adressée lorsqu'on
est frappé les gens doivent entendre
dont il est temps d'entendre pour prisé
des finances c'est important dope les
voisins qu'ils entendent par eux pas
dessus la fenêtre ou pas se passe là bas
doivent aussi pouvoir toc élabore dire
bonjour madame bon je me suis dit est-ce
que tout va bien ça il faut le faire ça
c'est une première chose ensuite alerté
la famille proche ou loin par des
réseaux sociaux ça arrive whatsapp sms
messages mais aussi appelé la police
donc encore une fois c'est un j'ai envie
de dire c'est un problème sociétal de
protéger les femmes victimes de
violences au sein des foyers
tout le monde est concerné merci
beaucoup noël ragusa d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association aide des
familles de victimes de féminicide voilà
une grande interview à retrouver sur
notre site arte france point tv mais
aussi en podcast à très bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]